in this video i'm going to show you the
seven ways to measure business value
and how you're probably being deceived
by most people you see on the internet
simply because you're not understanding
the words and terms they're using
all right so by the end of this video
you'll understand who's bs who's legit
who's real who's fake and if they
haven't given you
enough information to make the decision
exactly what questions to ask
all right so let's dive in so the first
of the seven types of ways that people
will measure value
is that they will extrapolate a single
month of contract value into eternity or
at least over a year
example what that looks like is someone
you know selling a yearly contract at an
event
they sell a hundred people at that event
let's say uh for thirty thousand dollars
a year
and they say we're doing three million
dollars a month
right crazy but the reality is they sold
three million dollars of contracts that
are unenforceable to people
on monthly uh income streams or monthly
cash flow
and so a hundred people at twenty five
hundred dollars a month
is what will get you to that thirty
thousand dollars right roughly what that
really means is they did two hundred
fifty thousand dollars at that event
but they said i'm doing three million
dollars a month
right even though it was a one-time
event that is not going to recur
and they based it on contra value
contract value and not payments
collected
and so the first way to see through this
stuff is to say well how much
money was actually collected and how
reliable are the contracts that you're
actually selling
if you have highly uh you know secured
contracts with companies that are legit
or you have them secured against assets
meaning that the likelihood that they
continue is high
or you have a net negative churn company
meaning the contract increases in value
over time based on the business
economics that you have like salesforce
for example
when you sign a contract with salesforce
you sound a contract with hubspot which
is another crm
most of those clients increase how much
they spend over time and so that would
be legit in that instance but the vast
majority of people who are saying this
to you
are not being legit and so first thing
to look out for
at the very end i'll give you my rating
for each of these
ways of doing it all right the second is
lifetime revenue so this is when someone
says
we've done x amount of total revenue
collected in our business now a lot of
times we'll say i have a
i mean i see an ad right now that i run
all the time it's like how i built a 50
million dollar business
but they mean how much revenue they've
collected over the lifetime of the
business
and so for context of how ridiculously
inflated this will be
mcdonald's employee will collect a
million dollars in revenue
as income is honestly that's even better
because it's income it's not even
revenue but like
just to show you how ridiculous and
preposterous this is a mcdonald's
employee will collect that over the
entire lifetime if you work to
mcdonald's your whole life
right and so if you if you use this
metric then it's incredibly inflating
and it's great for your ego and it
sounds good to impress people who don't
know what you're talking about okay and
so
you may have seen one of my videos that
said 122 million in revenue
uh for for me and i do that a because
the headline is more compelling than
saying you know we've done
mid-30s for the last three or four years
you know i'll play the game too
but understanding what that comes from
and so that's why i try and be as honest
as possible like well this is what we
did in revenue this is what we did in
profit
so that i can just be transparent with
everybody so you know at least what to
look for
and so when someone says we have a 50
million business or 100 million dollar
business
ask them are you talking about yearly
revenue are you talking about
profit like what are you talking about
specifically when you say that number
right and a lot of times we're like well
i i meant i guess that's how much you
know
total revenue we've done you know since
we started now mind you most
entrepreneurs especially newer
entrepreneurs will
conflate they will mix revenue with cash
collected
right those are two very different
things right revenues is
is contract value right but cash
collected
is really reality and so they'll use
this term and for the purpose of this
video when i say revenue i mean cash
collected what was processed
and received by the business so the
second way that people
describe their values how much total
revenue they've done in their lifetime
so you may actually have seen
you can see this award counter over here
i got for doing 100 million or passing
100 million
in total revenue in three years three
and a half years i think
since we started with clickfunnels which
is a software that we use for landing
pages
and they recognize the people who are
top performers but again that's
revenue like it doesn't mean it means
cash collected but it that doesn't mean
that like
we're doing that per year now this year
is a breakout year and i'll tell you
what we do at the end of this year
because
we will be close to that number um i
don't think we'll cross 100 million this
year but
um we're we'll be really close number
three
is business valuation so this one is one
where it's based on
the market's value of the business if it
were sold so this is another way of kind
of inflating the the business that you
have
now this isn't necessarily an unfair way
of valuing your business
right based on its own value but the
thing is it all depends on who's the one
who's ascribing the value
what are they what are they using to
create that value i hear all the time
like
i think i'd be able to get 15 times top
line you don't know
squat right the market will pay what the
market will pay
all right and so for most businesses
that are small businesses so anything
that's under 5 million dollars a year in
revenue
most of those guys are getting two to
three times ebitda which is another
measurement i'm gonna get to in a second
which is the earnings before interest
tax amortization and depreciation right
and so those are business metrics uh
that is going to have a multiple scribe
to it
so if you're a mid market which would be
like 10 to 100 million dollars in
revenue per year
then you might have a six to eight times
multiple if you get above
100 million dollars then a lot of times
you can get into the you know 12s 15s
etc and most of the time that's done on
ebitda in a very very very rare number
of circumstances will they do it on top
line revenue
all right and that is in a fast growth
company that has high amounts of capital
that need to be reinvested in it that
they believe are going to give it
a strategic advantage for high gross
profits in the future
um that they're reinvesting capital into
all right and so that's where you know i
saw somebody recently saying that they
had
you know they stole their business for a
hundred times ebitda right
what that really means is that like and
this is where this is what i want
everybody to watch this video to be
thinking
well either they had a really really
crazy business or more likely they were
making almost no
profit in their business and just got a
high valuation because of or not even
necessarily a high valuation if they
if they're doing a you know 10 000 a
year in profit on a five million dollar
business
then if they sell for you know five
million dollars they get
500 times ebitda which is ridiculous
right but people do that because it
sounds impressive right so that's why
we're that's why we're going through
this so you can cut through the bs
and hopefully get better sources of
information which is kind of my goal
here is that you can measure
you can measure other entrepreneurs
value based on the true value that
they've been providing
all right so the next one here is yearly
revenue all right
so this is how much revenue a business
is doing yearly now we're getting a
little bit closer to reality here
now again revenue versus cash collected
it depends on the type of business if
you have a service business that's based
on recurring revenue and contracts then
you're gonna have contracts that are
factored into that if you had an
e-commerce business for example which is
purely transactional
then the revenue and cash collector can
be very close to each other right and
you know revenue would also not take
into account refunds chargebacks things
like that which then gets into net
revenue
i won't get into it there's a zillion
terms and just as a side note here
the reason there are so many terms is
because measuring value
is something that is one of the hardest
aspects of investing in business in
general is that
people want to figure out what is this
thing worth and so that's why they have
lots of different metrics that look at
and so for you as a
as a as a keen you know entrepreneur or
investor or
you know person who wants to grow within
the business world understanding all of
these metrics and how they work together
to to assess or get as close to true
value as possible
are these are going to be tools in your
in your skill set and some of these are
better and some of these are worse and
i'll get to my ratings in a second all
right
so yearly revenue is the next which is
just how much are you doing every year
in terms of
top line right now the next one is
profit or ebitda now these two things
are not necessarily the same
um but i'm going to say ebitda being
earnings before interest tax
depreciation and mortization
right um for most businesses this is
where
coming back to the business valuation if
you're mid market you're getting six to
eight if you're kind of smaller then
you're at you know two to three
sometimes four if you're doing really
well
or you have some sort of competitive
advantage and so and again and that may
sound soft to you in terms of those
numbers
but the reality is that a lot of people
just look at the the outliers which
catch all the news in the press but most
businesses every
you know businesses are sold every day
at 1x 2x 3x ebitda
all the time just no one wants to talk
about it right
and so this is even closer to reality so
if i'm looking at a business owner or
somebody's
trying to posture with me right the
eggplant measuring contest of
of of entrepreneurship they're gonna if
they're starting to talk to me about
these numbers i'm like hey bro like
what are we doing bottom line right what
are we doing bottom line per year this
is what i want to know and so
that leads me naturally to the next one
which is okay well
you've got a you've got a certain amount
of ebitda that's coming up but
depending on your type of business you
might have to reallocate all that money
back into the business to just maintain
your competitive advantage
which charlie munger warren buffett uh
they talk about how their least favorite
type of businesses are businesses that
require
lots of additional capital right now as
they've become gazillionaires
they have to find businesses like that
because they have to put their capital
to work but for the thing that created
their wealth was finding businesses that
did not require
a lot of additional capital that created
lots of survey says
net free cash flow so how much owner
earnings how much can you extract
from the business all right that's what
this nfcf
here is net free cash flow right and
i've talked about this in other videos
but this is
after i've reinvested profits in the
business to maintain and grow our
competitive advantage
how much can i as the owner take out the
reason this is so important is because a
lot of times you're not going to sell
a lot of times businesses fail there are
tons of risks that's why business is one
of the riskiest things to get into
most businesses do not succeed that's
just those are just the stats
right and 99 times out of 100 your
business never actually sells you might
do an asset sale or a garage sale but
doesn't actually sell for what you think
it is which is why for me
as an entrepreneur you want to de-risk
by extracting cash flow and many times
this is one of the values of the
business and so if i'm talking to an
entrepreneur
and they tell me this then i'm going to
probably ask well what are you babe what
are you taking home and owner earnings
what are you extracting from business
what are you taking out as dividends
because i want to know what's reality
right and that leads me to the last
and the bottom one here and then i'll
give you my ratings on these which is
what's your net worth
right this is what entrepreneurs you
know everyone's shying away from talking
about
a lot of guys that you see on your
newsfeed those guys message me
and say hey man i want to do x y and z i
want to start investing et cetera and
they've got a half a million dollars for
their name
and they talk about how they've done 10
million dollars in revenue right
right lifetime and so again you could
just i'll give you a funny example for
you
so if someone um says hey we've done a
million dollars in revenue look at our
award right
that's over a total lifetime right that
could be over 10 years so if you did a
million dollars revenue for 10 years
means you're doing 100 000
a year in revenue right and if you're
doing 50
margins on that right that's a 50 000 a
year
owner income business which is just the
median income in the united states and
there's nothing wrong with that
but in terms of taking this person as an
authority i would be
i would be hesitant to to take their
advice
because candidly they're they're
probably just spending what they're
making on living
if that's how they're trying to position
so just just take that with a grain of
salt you know what i mean
and the reason i'm going through this is
because the best thing you can do
is learn from others but to make sure
that you're actually learning from
others learning from people who are good
information sources
is important and can there's tons of
people who know way more about business
but i just try to share the stuff that
has worked well for us
in creating you know for me an ultra
high net worth which is over 30 million
and there's two aspects of net worth all
right
you have your net worth that comes from
your investable assets which is what
you've extracted
right we've extracted paid your taxes on
and then been able to reinvest and grow
and the second is the percentage of the
businesses that you own business or
businesses that you own
all right which is why having a fair and
reasonable valuation is important
because what's the true market value of
the business that you have
now if someone says like my business
does like 10 million
a year and they do 2 million of ebitda
right and they're getting a
five times multiple on that because it's
truly a business it doesn't require
their face
if it requires their face then they're
not going to get that multiple right so
it's important to understand these
variables that create and measure value
in a business because if you're looking
for people and you're trying to listen
to advice
then make sure you're getting it from
the sources that are true and real again
two different ways that that can combine
to create net worth is going to be your
after tax
wealth that you've extracted from the
business and be able to reinvest on the
side and grow on your own
right and the percentages of the
businesses that you own the value around
them all right
so let's get to the good part which is
um yay or nay is this something that i'd
be looking at
uh in terms of uh whether i'm going to
value this person's opinion based on
this stat alone survey says contract
value
no i would not do that and that is
because
this can be wildly inflated especially
if you extrapolate on one month's
contract value for the rest of the year
it can be wildly inflated all right so
number two
lifetime revenue survey says no
i would not use this as a way of
measuring how good someone is at
uh at business because you want to know
how long was that was that over
20 years was it over 40 years because
that's what a mcdonald's employee can
earn
over that amount of time alright so
don't be impressed by this number
ask more questions which we which you
should hopefully do as we go down this
all right business valuation survey says
yes
but caveat on this you want to know what
type of multiple are you assuming
um and what is that off of top line or
bottom line and why can you defend that
right so this is asking good questions
so that you can actually get closer
to true value which is why all these
metrics even exist to begin with it's so
that people going to ascribe
and measure value all right next one
yearly revenue survey says
ah partial answer because it goes with
number five which is yearly profit
all right the difference here if
someone's doing 100 million dollars a
year
in top lane revenue and they're spitting
out um
just a little bit of profit that may be
okay right if you're doing 500 000
a year in profit i knew a company that
um 20 million in revenue 500 thousand
year profit they got sold for 168
million
right now that's a super valuable
business and it's because the bankers
and the people who bought it
saw that they had reinvested everything
right into growing the business
so understanding the relationship
between these two things if i have
another business that's doing 500 000
a year and a million dollars a year in
top lane revenue then it's to be a far
less valuable business
all right so understanding that they
might be making some strategic decisions
about how they're reinvesting the
business et cetera or some capital costs
that might have cost them but they see
what it's going to yield them in the
future
etc all right now um this is especially
true with software businesses
fyi all right which that particular
business was a software business
next one survey says yes on netflix flow
this is uncle warren this is uncle
charlie
munger this is their primary uh metric
for measuring business they try and
figure out what is the net free cash
flow after i
reinvest everything this is an excellent
way
excellent way to figure out the value of
the business all right because if you
can do your net free cash flow
and then you multiply it then you're
going to get very close to what an
investor
might be willing to pay for the asset
excluding some sort of crazy monopoly
thing that they're trying to get with
some sort of category king
uh you know situation in a marketplace
and then finally
net worth how do we see this on the on
the valuing of
uh eggplant right survey says
yes i think this is an excellent measure
uh of value because this is what is left
after
all the chips all the chips have fallen
all the cookies have crumbled
all the uh the roosters have roosted
this is what's left after everything
right because if you you know if you
like i've had 13 businesses
and i now own eight more so i've had 21
businesses right
um so i've had a lot of these things and
the thing that remains is you
your net worth is an entrepreneur and if
you look at the fortune 500 and you look
at it 50 years ago what you'll see is
that there's only two businesses that
are still on
the the fortune 500 from now from 50
years ago g and ford
that's it that's it right and so when
you think about that
a lot of times what what business
becomes is you create something and then
as an entrepreneur
you want to be able to create enough
personal wealth throughout the
trajectory of the business that's like
literally all businesses
fortune 500 and only two of them right
are still there
and so thinking about that that should
hopefully shift your perspective which
is why i'm so big on
extracting dividends while the business
is growing and i know that that might
not be as popular in the silicon valley
world but
a lot of those guys don't live in
reality and for the everyday business
owners everyday entrepreneurs that are
you know hustling out there
trying to make a buck trying to feed
their families it's important to de-risk
because you can't put all your eggs in
the single basket that is my opinion
sure you can bet on yourself but there
are so many more stories of guys who bet
everything on themselves at the casino
and walked away empty-handed
all right and so it is my belief that if
you were generating a profit you should
be purposely taking some out
every month even though the like for me
the vast majority of my net worth is in
my business valuations
still i still have you know over
whatever a lot
um in in in investable assets um that
categorizes me as ultra high net worth
all right and so
again ultra net worth just so you know
from the definition standpoint is
investable assets it's not based on
total value
these are the seven ways that i wanted
to highlight for measuring value
if you see someone and they say i am
worth this or my business is worth this
or i built an
x million dollar business ask these
questions
is that lifetime revenue is that
contract value that's been extrapolated
is that your business valuation based on
what multiple
is that based on a top line multiple or
is that based on a bottom line multiple
what's the net free cash flow what are
you taking out as dividends every year
and then finally
if someone will share it with you which
i i'm actually not that opposed
to sharing net worth numbers i know some
people are i don't really know why i
figure if you make enough money over
time people always end up finding out
what your net worth is which is
basically the entire forbes list and so
anyways
these are the ways that you measure
value these are my two second snap
judgments on them
and if you have if you have your astute
cap on then you probably figured out
that a lot of these things go together
right and it's not just one number it's
understanding the interplay between them
so that you can ascertain
with the true value of a business and or
the entrepreneur that owns it is
so hope you found valuable in that i
hope you found valuable in that hit the
subscribe button if you did
and if you didn't then don't hit the
subscribe button uh leave a comment if
you have any other questions or other
things that you would like
me to talk about because i just like to
make the stuff that you guys want
because that's what this is for
all right so it's for you guys so i hope
this found valuable and keeping awesome
i'll catch you guys
bye